[Music]
hi guys it's quinn here if you enjoy my
videos consider hitting the like button
it's the only way the youtube algorithm
really notices me
the technical term for modern humans is
homo sapien sapien
we are the current iteration of a genus
going back two million years
there were however obviously many
species of humans who did not go on
who for whatever reason could not adapt
to their environments well enough to
carry on their dna
examples include homo neanderthalensis
homo erectus and homo flor siennas
peter watts
in his novel blind sight merely adds an
additional species to that list
they evolved in a different way
the wrong way
this particular species of humans lack
the ability to synthesize the protein
protocaterine y
which other species of humans produced
naturally
their brains and bodies were different
as well
they were smarter stronger and faster
than other humans
and in earlier eras of humanity when
myth and legend were still being formed
they prayed upon us in the night
ancient humanity was only able to drive
them to extinction when they discovered
that the creatures had an aversion to
right angles this trait had developed
naturally through some fluke of genetics
it was seemingly neutral at first as
right angles do not form very often in
nature
but once this fact was revealed to
humanity they drove them back into the
darkness seemingly forever
until many eons later when science
brought them back
in the age of space exploration humans
needed to find a way to be able to
survive the necessary conditions for
long-term hibernation in space
for this reason they resurrected the
vampires though they did not repair the
gene which gave them their aversion to
right angles the crucifix glitch
it is mentioned that they could have if
they wanted to
they extracted the traits which gave
them the potential for long-term
hibernation and gave it to certain
humans who would travel in deep space
blindside follows the crew of the
spacecraft theseus all of which are
human hybrids except one
their leader saresti
who was a vampire
the crew understood that if he so chose
he could prey upon them at any time this
created tension
they knew that the psychology of
vampires had to be different from their
own
and the back and forth of whether or not
humanity can trust the resurrected
vampires definitely adds to the uneasy
feeling of the book
vampires had to be sociopaths
they're too much like their own prey
a lot of taxonomists don't even consider
them a subspecies you know that never
diverged far enough for reproductive
isolation so maybe they're more syndrome
than race just a bunch of obligate
cannibals with a consistent set of
deformities
and how does that make if the only thing
you can eat is your own kind empathy is
going to be the first thing that goes
psychopathy is no disorder in those
shoes eh
just a survival strategy but they still
make our skin crawl so we chain them up
you think we should have repaired the
crucifix glitch everyone knew why we
hadn't only a fool would resurrect a
monster without safeguards in place
vampires like serasti had to constantly
take anti-euclideans which kept them
from short-circuiting in the presence of
right angles serasti also hides a lot
and he's only ever really seen when he
needs to be seen
the other crew members of theseus can't
tell if this is because he knows that he
makes them nervous or because
the vampire doesn't fully trust himself
around them either way it's somewhat
unnerving when also added to the fact
that cerresti has the tendency to
seemingly appear out of nowhere the
actual reason serasti hides likely goes
back to primitive instinct
in the early days of mankind when his
kind stalked us in the night
they did it from the shadows
he hid and waited because it was his
nature to hide and wait and that was the
nature of all the vampires that get
resurrected
it wasn't just serasti
they all hid from us
even when they had the upper hand
they always stayed just the other side
of myth
it started pretty much the same way it
did for anything else
vampires were far from the first to
learn the virtues of energy conservation
shrews and hummingbirds saddled with
tiny bodies and overclocked metabolic
engines would have starved to death
overnight if not for the torpor that
overtook them at sundown
comatose elephant seals lurked
breathless at the bottom of the sea
rousing only for passing prey or redline
lactate levels
bears and chipmunks cut costs by
sleeping away the impoverished winter
months and longfish devonian black belts
in the art of estivation could curl up
and die for years waiting for the reigns
with vampires it was little different
it wasn't shortness of breath or
metabolic overdrive or some blanket of
snow that locked the pantry every winter
the problem wasn't so much a lack of
prey
as a difference from it vampires were
such a recent split from the ancestral
baseline that the reproductive rates
hadn't diverged this was no woodland
variety lynx hair dynamic where prey
outnumbered predators a hundred to one
vampires fed on things that bred barely
faster than they did
they would have wiped out their own food
supply in no time if they hadn't learned
how to ease off on the throttle
by the time they went extinct they'd
learned to shut down for decades it made
two kinds of sense it not only slashed
their metabolic needs while prey bred
itself back to harvestable levels it
gave us time to forget that we were prey
we were so smart by the pleistocene
smart enough for easy skepticism
if you haven't seen any night stalking
demons in all your years on the savannah
why would you believe some senile
campfire ramblings passed down by your
mother's mother
it was murder on our ancestors
even if those same enemy genes co-opted
now served us so well when we left the
sun fifty thousand years later but it
was almost heartening i guess to think
that maybe soresty felt the tug of other
genes some aversion to prolonged
visibility shaped by generations of
natural selection
maybe he spent every moment in our
company fighting voices that urged him
to hide
hide
let them forget
i really enjoy the interpretation of
vampires in this book typically vampires
are depicted in the vein of bram stoker
and have supernatural elements to them i
appreciate watts's science fiction
explanation for vampires because for me
that makes it creepier also i find the
description of earlier humanity living
in a world where vampires would sleep
for decades only to be reawakened after
humans had forgotten to be truly creepy
the lore watt sets up surrounding
vampires and the history of their
genetics is extremely compelling and i
honestly wish there was more of it in
the book but the mere fact that a
vampire is on the crew of theseus helps
to elevate the other horror elements of
this book the crew of theseus itself are
the first crewed mission sent to learn
more about the alien race which had
scanned the earth suddenly and vanished
years ago
the ominous atmosphere set up by this
book is extremely impressive and that's
due to the combination of the tension
between saresti and the crew and due to
their mysterious interactions with the
alien vessel which speaks to them using
a human voice
now just in case you missed it earlier i
put out this video on the blind site
where i go deeper into the main theme of
the book the necessity of consciousness
if you like these kinds of videos on
science fiction books check out my
channel and make sure you like and
subscribe for more quinn's ideas
just a heads up for those of you that
may be interested my next graphic novel
the lie behind the star is launching
february 2023 you can sign up now to get
on the email mailing list to get
notified as soon as it launches more
information on my website link in the
description thank you guys so much
[Music]
you